this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu well I'm I work at the
Charles pol community health center and
something happened to my slides but I am
formerly the coordinator for the health
disparities research training program
and my current role there is actually to
managing the old appetites fee programs
there but i'm here to present today
addressing health disparities in the
Asian American Pacific Islander
community by fostering community-based
research through the health disparities
research training program I just wanted
to start by giving you some background
on on the need so for those of you who
might not be terribly familiar with with
our community the API population is
fastest-growing of America's ethnic
groups and so we're currently a ten
point six million and and we're
projected to grow to about 40 1,000,000
by 2050 according to the u.s. census and
we we in our own in our own literature
searches have found that we have a lot
of unidentified looking you said oh
great um so in our own so in our own
litter view of what the health needs of
the AAPI community in just really
general searches we come up with very
little and there's a huge gaps in the
data for for aap eyes and there's such a
range of difference between the East
Coast and the west coast
tend smaller pockets of API communities
in the middle parts of the country in
the American South and we are often as a
group generalized I mean the term Asian
alone includes so many different
cultures and so many different ethnic
groups you know subgroups people speak
different dialects and all kinds of
languages and it's a really generalize
charm and so we find that we're often
kind of shoved in that other category or
we don't appear at all and many in many
ethnic writedowns when one comes to data
and so we find that it's it's one of the
reasons is that we labor under the smile
of minority myth and it predicates this
assumption that our community is you
know I always say model minority model
health and so you know it makes it seem
as if this community doesn't doesn't
have any health needs you know I'm
they're doing well economically they're
doing well they're doing well in schools
they have the highest highest rates of
graduation rates and you know high
levels of education but but it's but
there's actually no proof of that
there's actually very little
surveillance in our community about
about health in particular um so another
reason that we see these gaps that we
believe that we see these gaps is that
aps are poorly represented in community
research and so you know i mean it's
it's a very common stereotype that
asians are you know where oh you know we
do well in school and you know we become
doctors and lawyers and and while we are
very well represented in health field
were not really well represented in
health and health research and that
becomes a problem because
um certainly my own experience in our in
our research at the health center we
find that a lot of the a lot of the
research that's out there is actually
not very culturally competent and we see
a lot of sort of you know blisters and
bubbles in in the way that the community
is described in a way that in the way
that we were sorry in a way that were
described in the way that where we
approached as a community and in this in
sort of so-called community-based
participatory research and we find that
we're not really participating in that
research and yet it we see all this
research that's called that and it's
we're not you know no one's on the radar
to have ever participated in any of this
research
so um so the Hudson urges research
training program was formed in 2003 by
the Charles be wonky knee health center
and the Center for the Study of asian
american health i'll start with the
center of asian for the study of asian
american health in 2003 at the c sub
which is what we call it for short was
received a grant from the national
institutes of health and in the national
center for minority health and health
disparities to create a center of a sort
of study of asian american health so
this is a very unique campus partnership
and there are about forty
community-based organizations and the
new york city hospitals and clinics and
then my school of medicine that work
together to create a trigger eight the
center and together these partners
develop initiatives in four key areas
and one get these right in research
education and training community
assessment and community outreach and
partnerships the Charles be welcoming
health center is we're actually
approaching our 40th year in Chinatown
it was actually started in 1971 by a few
a few people in the neighborhood
basically who saw that there was the
health needs of the chinatown community
we're not being met and you know people
were there was a large immigrant
population people were people had very
different different kinds of cultural
beliefs about going to see a doctor and
what kind of doctor they saw resorting
to a lot of traditional medicine
possibly and and very different myths
and and health beliefs that they took
from from their their mother country
when they came to the to the united
states and so a few
a few and it's hard for me to describe
this because many of them are now much
older'n and on our on our board at the
health center but you know when they
were all young with long hair and
mustaches and you know bell-bottoms they
were walking around Chinatown trying to
get everybody in China don't care about
health and so they managed to close down
a few streets to launch a health fair
and that's how the Charles be one
community health center began and was
formerly known as the Chinatown health
clinic before Charles be wrong had
donated money to our organization so the
alt disparities research wing program is
administered by me at the at the health
center and it's it's a program that
allows us to create an environment for
for people who are interested in doing
research in in the AAPI community in New
York City to give them a chance to link
up with all the essential people that
they need to to launch a research
project
so our objectives and we like to
increase competence and commitment among
students as I said earlier there are
large gaps in in the data in our in the
data of our community and we would like
to encourage people who are going into
the health field to to think about
public health and to think about
research and filling those gaps in the
data by by conducting research and and
many people who go into health field in
in the API community are have access to
huge huge data data banks at their
health centers or in you know whatever
it is that they may be working at their
community centers and so it's a great
deal of access to a lot of information
that can be very important in how we
address health in the API community we
want to increase the number of potential
investigators and and as I said earlier
increase the number of research projects
addressing health disparities among
Asian American populations we want
provide skills and tools develop a
culturally relevant research study so we
want cultural relevance and we want
country look cultural competency when
people address our our community and
through this program we hope to get
people who are part of the community to
actually conduct the research and so we
can sort of assure that that will have a
little more cultural competency a little
more sensitivity and how this research
is conducted in how community groups and
academic groups are approached and it
when when we conduct research
we'd like to provide we provide a unique
opportunity learn strategies to analyze
compile inseminate research we bring
together a lot of and many many of our
faculty volunteer with us and we bring
together a lot of good boot some of the
great experts in in our field are
locally to come together and and sort of
share the knowledge and spread the
knowledge and create a network for for
research and for just simply for
resources as well so we breed we create
that bridge for the potential researcher
and the academic institution or if you
know if it's it's an academic who is
interested in doing research in the
community we bridge them with the
community organization
so this very convoluted chart is the the
rundown of our and I'm sorry it's not as
clear as it should be it's basically the
rundown of our of our training program
and so we begin with with a background
we start with an overview of our
community and its it was formerly a
three-day seminar and now it's been
reduced down to one day and and explain
why and Anna later slide we start with
an overview of the community and we will
often find that we're preaching to the
choir but we do feel it's important to
at least dress those issues particularly
if there are trainings that year who are
not as familiar with the a community in
New York because as I said before many
of the API communities on the west coast
are very different from the ones on the
east coast and after that or that
orientation day we begin with with
providing tools and so we do we do
research methods for both qualitative
and quantitative research we we help
them decide how how to create what kind
of sample to use and how to create that
sample on how to collect data what are
the notes nuts and bolts of starting a
research project then we launch into a
few months later we launch into the
application part and that's the data
analysis part so hopefully at this point
about three to three or four months into
the program the trainees have collected
some amount of data Oh some of them have
been very fortunate to use secondary
data amongst or some of our former
trainees and they've they're able to
start on the data analysis part and
what's really great about about this
part of the process of the training
program is that we can we we have a very
small intimate group it's about six to
eight trainees per year and we sit
around table and we brainstorm and
everyone shares their progress in the
work
you know I'm having I'm having a lot of
trouble getting in touch with this
organization you know and then another
person will provide provide a different
organization or some other way to two
approaches community or you know
sometimes there are concerns in an
individual's working on their project
and another person raises the question
of concern that maybe they're not
approaching it in the right way or
they're missing something in the way
that they're approaching in and maybe
that's why they're not getting their
data so it's a very it's a very great
opportunity and way to for all of us to
workshop with each other on our on each
individual project and of course we
typically have our speaker in the room
and so the speaker will usually conduct
that roundtable discussion and then
after after we're done with the tools
and and the application we come to the
sort of the conference period where we
we let them work independently for a
while and then we keep on them we see if
they've they've conducted you know all
their data collection and if they've
finally done all their their analysis of
their data and we we get them ready by
by asking you to prepare an abstract for
the asian american health conference
this year the asian american health
conference will actually be an opto in
the beginning of october so it's there's
a little bit of a lag there and they
have they have spots open or a setup for
them there's no there's no real
application process and so they'll
automatically accepted into into the
conference and they're given opportunity
to get a feel for what a conference
presentation is like and and an
opportunity to share their data prior to
that we try to set up a time where at
our
at the health center all those trainees
are able to share their share their work
with members of sisa and n charles be
wrong and a lot of sort of a rehearsal
time for them before they present their
their presentations at the seesaw
conference so the way we we choose the
trainees is that we have a training poor
committee and that's made up of faculty
and staff from from both the CPW and C
so we basically we come together we sort
of brown baguette and just talk about
each of the the applicants usually we
have about roughly 10 to 15 applicants
and we pare that down from there our
eligibility criteria well we try to be
as flexible as possible I mean these are
some of the criteria we try to be as
such as well as possible because some
some people have more experience than
others and some may not have as much
academic background but have a lot more
experience and so we try to be as
flexible as possible and we try to look
at each applicant as a whole
so the program basically includes
sharing being able to share a practical
knowledge and experience with the the
speakers and said they go through a
monthly seminar series and they're also
paired up if you look at that large
arrow they're also paired up with the
mentor the mentors are often the
speakers that come monthly some of the
trainees will bring someone they have in
mind that they've been dying to work
with they really want to do research
with them and so we try to make that
happen through our web of contacts and
and get them connected to the person
that they really want to work with and
who has some has their own vested
interest in the research project sit and
there are several written assignments
and we try to have them keep sort of a
blog of their progress and so that we
know how they're doing and and we know
that they're communicating us with us if
there's any problems or if there is any
way we can help them facilitate on their
research so here are some of the
outcomes again I apologize for the tiny
type for research topic areas it really
runs a range and and and we really try
in choosing our trainees we really try
to do when we look at the entire package
of each applicant we really try to think
about you know what what areas are
really what a hot topic areas in the
community where were the gaps in the
community that we need the information
and so we have been very fortunate to
have trainees who have these they come
with ideas for different areas in the
community were there isn't data and they
would like to really look at
what's going on and why don't we have
the data and why isn't there a
literature out there so we've been very
fortunate in that respect the alumni and
even currently we have I mean this
current group that we have have it
consists of a pharmacist's one thank you
one person who works for the EPA we have
a physical therapist we have one person
wants to work on mental health their
social worker at NYU and alumni output
and we have people who present at
different conferences other than see
compensation conference we've had to
publish managed scripts and several
submissions that and some were not
accepted alumni alumni outcomes range
they we have we have different parts
that we had sorry we have different
trainees who have either crew completed
their research we're hopeful that they
can create their you complete the
research we are only we were only 12
month program up until this year and now
we're a 15 month program is but it's
very difficult to encourage CBPR which
takes several years to get together to
even start the data collection and to
build those relationships it's very
difficult to ask a group of of eight ave
trainees to to create those
relationships in 15 months and get their
data collection analyzed and get ready
for presentation
so lessons learned that be flexible we
have been very very flexible and a large
part of the job of the training
coordinator is just keeping up with
everyone and chasing them down I you
know anyone's ever worked with students
in this capacity know that you know it's
it add the work ebbs and flows and so
you really have to make sure that people
are doing everything and many of our
trainees are full-time fully full-time
employed somewhere or are full-time
students and so they all sometimes
forget that they have things to do and
and that this research to do we're also
a free program and we don't provide a
stipend and so we often find that that
the incentive is not there for them to
to get everything done and completed um
we really want to always want to
schedule time for discussion again as I
said the workshop the work shopping
times are really important to the
trainees they often asked for it they
often complain if there's not time for
the workshop periods sometimes I would
set up a separate time with them and we
would separately without a speaker have
a separate discussion group so that we
can all brainstorm together and you know
allow the curriculum to evolve over time
the curriculum is on last slide has has
changed over time and we've added things
that we thought were now more salient
and we learned from what what our
curriculum was in the past and we've
changed it to accommodate the needs of
the trainees and every year in our in
our application process we ask the
training is what you know what they're
what they're looking for in terms of
being able to conduct the research
and you know these other people like so
now a lot of people are involved in
working on this many of them are no
longer with either organization but are
still very much involved and and you
know as you see I mean as these people
leave the organization they become a
large network and we keep growing that
network we really look at the health
disparities research training program as
a prototype for other areas particularly
areas where there isn't a terribly large
API population but but a significant one
that would really like to look at their
community and see you know what's going
on why is this such a silent community
you know it's you know how can we break
through that model minority myth and see
what's going on and see and see how many
you know what disease areas we need to
focus on what you know do we need to get
people to exercise more do we need to
get people to eat better are they are to
have access to two resources on health
information you know we really want to
be able to provide a prototype for those
areas to create a relationship with an
academic institution or just or
academics in the area or close by that
can work with community organization
come together and find out what's going
out into the community thank you very
much
are there any questions comments oh yes
research
the
bye
ok
my
right one one example I can think of is
one of our change from last year focused
on substance use and and I face up since
uses both substance abuse because it's
in in in our key in our community many
of the researchers in our community
don't like to use the word abuse and
prefer to use use as a more it's a pro
more proactive term and I raise that
example because it's not it's not
necessarily a distinct a distinct health
issue in in the community and perhaps
the point is that we want to generalize
our populations day and make our
population general and say that you know
we have all the same problems as all the
other groups we just need to find out
what those issues are and where we need
to focus our attention you know it's
it's it's not my Nordic model minority
model health and we are as an
organization we this program really
starts the seed of generating that
information and and then hopefully
dispensing it and you know that's the
point of of the tail end of the program
where we where we have conference
abstracts and we really help them to
disseminate the information by printing
by printing health information which
materials for patients where they work
or without the community groups that
they've worked with on their project and
also to to have a data bank for people
who might be interested in in you know
substance use we've had people who work
on cvd we have people who work on men
mental health and so we have created
this hodgepodge of different disease
areas health very different health
issues and we put them all into a sort
of data bank and hopefully people will
approach
institue Ascot sefino you know i'm
looking i'm curious about mental health
issues in the community what can I work
and I find information and many times
people do approaches for that and we've
been able to help them another way is is
to sort of get get buy-in from the
community and from from health care
providers is we've managed to link
health disparities with many different
programs and one of the programs that I
manage is the beef receipt partnership
with NYU Medical and sisa and we take
two of our trainees from program and and
who might not be terribly sure what area
they want to focus on in terms of health
charities in the community and what what
topics they want to research and we we
have sort of turned them on to doing
research in hepatitis B and we identify
areas that we've discovered that there
are gaps in information and and we are
able to through that through that grant
we're able to provide them with with a
small amount of funding to conduct focus
groups quote to you know collect street
surveys and whatever the case may be
that answer your question are there any
other questions yep
first of all up
r33
Oh
those second-generation vs
here
you are
so some significant areas I've noticed
particular with our with our trainees is
is actually mental health I think it's
very actually out I'm going to increase
that to mental health and sexual health
I think those are two areas where
certain things are just not spoken of in
the community and when we do our work we
have this sort of intuitive way of
interested addressing things so if I'm
if I'm working with the patient or I'm
conducting an interview with a patient
or filling out a survey with patient
there's a certain way that I'll present
information and and what somewhat
unfortunate about that is that we do it
intuitively we we don't have to think to
do it we are well because the world
aware of issues in the community and so
you know something like mental health is
very we had an incident the other the
other Jay without disclosing too much
information where our psychiatrist was
in had had said something that normally
maybe to a person of a different culture
would not we're not find offensive but
it was it was something as simple as
saying that she was sad and so she she
ran out of his office we were all
sitting in our office across the hall
and we just heard commotion and there
you know she's sort of yelling at him in
Cantonese and saying you know you're
saying that I'm sad and I don't want to
talk to you and that was that was the
end of discussion and he just he pleaded
with her for maybe about an hour in the
hallway and finally she went back into
the office to talk about it and he he
and his expert opinion saw that she was
very suicidal and he had to address it
somehow and so he had to figure out some
other way to address it in a more
culturally sensitive way
in terms of sexual health hepatitis B is
is a big area that we're we're we've
looked into for the the fast I believe
five years now and we've we've launched
these huge screening programs and we
keep finding each year we find more and
more people who who are infected and
many of them are actually coming from
from abroad and so they're there you
know such a the Chinatown community in
particular is a very very transient
community and so we have people who
might you know we have to catch them on
the right day because people work seven
days a week or they're only in New York
City for on Mondays on their day off and
then all the other days they I mean they
travel very far for work and so you know
there are DC most of the week they come
back monday and and we have to catch
them to do screenings and to to get them
to their doctors appointments so you
know I mean there's a lot of sort of
difficult migratory issues that were
that we're working with and they're even
even amongst just the Chinese Chinese
population there are subgroups and you
know so we're we're we're getting people
immigrating in from places where happy
is its endemic and so and so we're aware
of this and so we're keeping an eye and
eye out and making sure that people fill
in the box that tells us where what
province you are from and so that way we
can generate data and say and say look
there's there's a problem in this with
this community we have we have to do
more screening and then beyond the
screening we have to get treatment and
so we're sort of at that point where
we're trying to create a collaborative
care system in the health center for
hepatitis B patients and making sure
that they're getting quality care
in in a timely fashion and making sure
that they're coming back for their
visits and they understand that this is
a salient issue and you know they may
feel fine but there's something going
wrong on their bodies that they need to
be very aware of and very very careful
of and that's a little hard to drill
home and and you know and you know
people are very willing to say you know
I can't afford drugs hepatitis B
medication per year costs I'm sorry per
month costs eight hundred dollars a
month that's higher than most people's
rent rent money and in in Chinatown is
particularly in single row African
occupancy homes that they live in and so
and so you know trying to convince them
that they should pay eight hundred
dollars a month for their medication
when they feel fine is is a huge issue
in itself and it you know and language
is also a barrier because many of us
that the health center speak multiple
dialects but there's there's always
always at least 10 people per day who
speak a dialect that nobody in health
center speaks and so we have to find a
way we have to find someone and quick
you know I mean we're largely linked by
Mandarin but it's still you know you
know you might have you know American
Board Chinese like me who you know can
manage enough Mandarin but you know has
it has enough fluency but then you know
trying to speak with someone who doesn't
as who also has limited fluency and
trying to get those together and discuss
something as complicated as health in a
very difficult language is you know is
such an issue and so you know we we
encounter that every day there Venus
several times in this past month I've
been asked to to go downstairs and
trampoline someone who's speaking
Mandarin in someone's speaking Cantonese
and so there are all these issues there
that you just don't anticipate as you
just don't you know you don't think that
this an issue but we're grouped into
such a small into sorry large category
and we're so many small individual
groups
and especially in such a melting pot
like New York City we have so many
groups and you know people aren't always
aware of you know oh you know the large
population Fuji knees in New York City's
is is the recent development you know
and flushing has developed over the
years into what a lot of people call
little Taiwan because there's a lot of
Taiwanese there so it's it's you know
it's ever-evolving we just have we
always find yourselves having to keep up
because something that happens in China
if another area is starting to really
industrialize and develop people start
to leave and because they have more
money in there they are able to leave
and so they'll they'll insert this
Exodus and you know one of the major
places to come is to New York and so
then that shifts or population yet again
and we have to find a way to address uh
you know you know people from a
different problems with a different
dialect yet again and so we're always
playing this game of catch up but
traditionally in Chinatown people it's
largely Cantonese so many people at the
health center who've been here for many
years largely speak Cantonese and I'm
actually in the minority that speaks
Mandarin and so we have we have these
these you know unanticipated issues
there that we're always trying to adjust
and catch up on sorry did I answer both
your question
so
come
mmm
um
there are so many
in the area
I
I like you know right
problem
there's differently but there are
definitely cultural issues there I don't
I want to speak too much mental health
thing that I'm not an expert in any way
but you know there are there are a lot
of cultural issues there I mean
oftentimes you'll find that there's a
there's a cultural clash between young
folks and their and their parents and so
it's often that's you know you often get
parents who are not getting along with
their children and this you know the our
social workers will have to call will
have to call schools and have to call
teachers and parents and siblings and
cousins grandparents and just to figure
out the situation and deal with it so
there's a lot of culture clash in terms
of of that mental health i think it's
it's something that you know something
for me growing up I never talked about
those kinds of issues for me personally
I family and I can I can definitely say
there are some crazy people my family
and you know and there's this you know
we don't we don't form for me personally
I don't think it's an issue that is is
really addressed and people are open
about talking about it's one of those
things that oh that doesn't happen to
our community on something that that is
very similar to HIV where you know it in
in another life when I was doing HIV
advocacy there was in the community
there's a lot of hope that doesn't
happen to us you know we don't we don't
we don't get HIV and you know we don't
we're not promiscuous we don't we don't
have sex outside of marriage there are
no homosexuals in the AAPI community and
so you know they're there are those
issues they're all as well are there any
other questions I don't want okay
hmm
mm-hmm well we one of the ways we we
have the application on our website
that's cbw CHC org and then we again use
our network and so we go through NYU and
we we post on every single listserv any
kind of mostly mostly web-based emails
and anything we can get our hands on and
we announced it through that and I've
I'm a graduate of the mailman school and
so I use that I use that contact there
and you know we we we have contacted
stony broken and take John's and old
westbury we just we use as many of those
resources as possible and try to get in
as we even use idealist so and and we
get we get a good response typically I
mean 10 to 15 sounds very low but but
it's it's it's a huge commitment and we
are in in our advertisements for the for
the program we're very explicit about
about the amount of commitment and the
amount of time that will go into the
program and so I'm hoping that that's
the reason that you know we have a
smaller pool and the other good thing
about this small pool that we do get is
that it's it's they're all very high
caliber and our difficulties always
trying to pair that number down to the
six or eight that we get per year
absolutely we have we had the chief
medical officer at the Asian Pacific
Islander Coalition for hiv/aids apply
one year because he was uni he'd been a
doctor for so long he was really curious
about research and so he applied we had
someone who worked at the American
Cancer Society this year we have someone
from the Environmental Protection Agency
so you know we tried to be as culturally
diverse and also in terms of the
professions of each of the trainings we
try to be as diverse as possible to just
so that we stick to the whole idea of
diversity first of all and also to get
just get different perspectives and you
know how can we look at an issue
differently certainly that way are there
any other questions we thank you all
very much
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu